bearing witness Seeking Justice
videography in the hands of the people
as you all know from the murder of
George Floyd to the recent protests in
Iran
videography in the hands of the people
can play a key role in protecting our
rights and our civil liberties
at MIT we want to make the world a
better place
want to make the world a better place
you need to understand how it works
the new ways in which videography is
being used by the people
provide unprecedented data about the
workings of the society we live in
but these data won't deepen our
understanding of society on their own
we need the tools of the humanities in
the social sciences to interpret the
data with rigor
with perspective and with empathy
I hope that this conference will
contribute to that investigation
I'd like to thank our speakers
I'd like to thank students visiting from
the Hartford School District who will
provide their unique viewpoints as they
facilitated workshops
I'd like to thank the conferences
steering committee and everyone who
helped organize this event
it was a big job
and most of all I would like to thank
Professor Ken Manny
who came up with the vision for this
conference and who pushed very very hard
to make sure that it happened thank you
Captain
[Applause]
and now just as she walks in
it's my pleasure to hand the microphone
to
chance a system Dean for diversity
equity and inclusion Tracy Jones
thank you good morning everyone
good morning everyone
so I have the pleasure of introducing
Professor Heather Hendershot she studies
TV news conservative media political
movements and American film and
television history
she has held fellowships at Vassar
College
New York University Princeton Harvard
Radcliffe and Stanford and she has also
been in Guggenheim fellow
her courses at MIT emphasize the
interplay between creative political and
Regulatory concerns
and how those concerns affect what we
see on the screen big or little
have to take a deep breath
students in her class are encouraged to
consider the ways that TV and film
writers directors and producers have
attempted Innovation while working
within an industry that demands novelty
but also often fears new approaches to
character and narrative
professor professor Hendershot is the
editor of Nickelodeon no Nation
the history politics and economics of
America's only TV channel for kids
and the author of Saturday morning
censors
television regulation before the V chip
shaking the world for Jesus media and
conservative Evangelical culture
what's fair on the air
cold world right wing broadcasting and
the public interest
and open to debate
how William F Buckley put liberal
America on the firing line
for five years she was the editor of
Cinema Journal
the official publication of the society
for Cinema and media studies
her latest book when the news broke
Chicago 1968 and the polarizing of
America is forthcoming from the
University of Chicago press this fall
now I'd like to welcome Professor
Heather hindershot to the stage
[Applause]
thank you for that introduction
and there we go thank you for that
introduction thank you all for coming
I'm really honored to be the opening
plenary speaker for the conference
uh and to spending the next day or two
with you
um as a media historian uh my objective
is always to tell stories about the past
go to archives find new information
about the past five news ways of
understanding what happened but also to
think about how those stories about the
past can help us think through various
issues in the present
and so that is uh part of what I'm going
to be doing today in uh telling you
about
material for my book when the news broke
that Tracy just mentioned
um which is a book about Chicago in 1968
in August during the Democratic National
Convention it is a story of
authoritarianism of police brutality
and uh for our purposes for thinking
about uh issues of media and Technology
it's a story of top-down media
production to a large extent
that is to say a media produced by
companies or like acbs and NBC or by you
know sort of legitimately authorized
kinds of journalists so from magazines
and newspapers and to a lesser extent
from some underground newspapers some
smaller uh sort of counter-cultural
Productions
um
it is also a story about media
production circumscribed by a number of
concrete technological limitations uh
and I'm going to go into a number of
those throughout my presentation over
the next 45 minutes and it's also a
story with with repercussions with
Fallout with um you know following this
convention the notion of liberal media
bias
um
uh that we hear bandied about uh sort of
took root in American culture it had
been seen as a kind of peripheral
extremist notion the idea that the media
was liberal that CBS and NBC were
liberal because they were seen as very
very neutral kind of players and you
know this idea that the the media has
liberal biases is almost quaint now in
the light of accusations of fake news
and enemy of the people sort of talk and
the kind of polarization that we're
seeing so we're going back to a sort of
primordial moment that in some ways
helps us understand how we got from
there to here to where we are right now
um so as I said I'm drawing uh from this
book that's coming out in December
um let me start by sort of setting the
scene okay so the book looks at four
days in Chicago and the aftermath of
those four days when the Democrats
gathered to choose their next candidate
for president and vice president and
Lyndon Baines Johnson the president had
declined to run again and it was assumed
that the candidate would be his vice
president Hubert Humphrey but thousands
of delegates came in and uh
uh many of them hoped that there would
be a different candidate or that at
least if it were Hubert Humphrey the
vice president that he would have a
tempered platform on Vietnam he would
have a different approach to Vietnam
okay so that's the basics
the bigger story uh to help us
understand going into Chicago is the
scene in America at the time uh that
we're in a kind of Tinderbox situation
um
it's clear that we are not just about to
win the war in Vietnam which is what the
government have been telling people for
a couple of years there had been a
number of high-profile assassinations
Robert F Kennedy was assassinated in
June which uh uh was shocking and he was
expected to be a strong Contender to be
the nominee for president he would have
had a peace platform Martin Luther King
is assassinated
um in April and there's a number of
urban uprisings all over the country
following the assassination of King and
of course that had been going back to
earlier in the 60s starting with the
famous Watts uprising of 1965 and this
is the smallest list of cities where
where these uh uprisings happen do you
see Newark Detroit famously in 1967 was
basically on fire for an entire week
um and then Chicago had an uprising
following the death of King
and uh you know there were there was a
great deal of shooting in the street and
the vast majority of people uh killed by
police were people of color right before
the Democratic Convention Chicago a week
or two before
um there have been a Republican National
Convention where they nominated Nixon uh
in Miami and there was an uprising there
about a mile away from the conference
and the uh Sheriff of Miami famously
said uh when this happened when the
Looting starts the shooting starts and
famously I say because it had some
traction at the time but then of course
more recently we heard the the former
president use exactly these words a
certain moment during the black lives
matters protest following the murder of
George Floyd
so it's a phrasing has a great deal of
resonance
so
the powder cake situation
um there are obviously some comparisons
we can make between then and now an
ongoing crisis of police brutality
particularly targeting people of color
there was a crisis of leadership then in
68 and because everything went so badly
in Chicago that really helped Richard
Nixon uh get elected to uh fulfill his
promise to restore Law and Order another
phrasing that the former president was
fond of using a sort of dog whistle to
Nixon for putting down people of color
and various other uh Progressive social
justice movements in the U.S
um
okay so that sets you up for just
America in 1968 uh very briefly uh the
other thing to think about heading into
Chicago is what I call a sort of
infrastructure of censorship uh there
are a lot of technological limitations
that the mayor of Chicago mayor Richard
Daly had put into place and it's it's
pretty detailed I won't go into all of
them but a key one is that there was an
electrical worker strike that uh
basically prevented live coverage of the
convention outside the convention hall
and it was standard for Network news
people to leave the convention and go to
the hotels where the candidates were and
to interview them but also in this
particular convention There Were Ten
Thousand protesters in the streets there
was a story to be told in the streets
and that was very very hard to do
because as this Electrical Workers
strike uh and Mayor Daley was a very um
authoritarian mayor he had the unions
kind of under his thumb and it was very
telling that this was the one strike
that he couldn't settle uh this was not
someone who who often dealt with the
problem of Strikers because the unions
were sort of in his back pocket he had a
lot of patronage jobs and so on so it's
no coincidence that the strike was not
resolved at this moment
um there are also technological
limitations that uh create were part of
this infrastructure of censorship as I
call it uh the limitations of of news
and image Gathering such as the camera
weights and sizes and so on I'll show
you some pictures of that in a minute
I'm going to try to stay away from all
these Tech study slides because it can
be boring you're like oh she's saying
the same thing that I'm reading up there
so I'm going to try to stick to lots of
pictures to kind of keep you keep you
awake keep going
um and finally I'll say that uh part of
this infrastructure of censorship was
that mainstream journalism had certain
professional Norms of fairness what we
now call both sidesism right that that
would be anachronistic to apply then
um but with only nbcc EBS and ABC doing
the news and NBC and CBS doing the
majority of the news in Chicago
um there was a sense that they should be
very neutral they should be fair to
everyone and that often meant
undercovering uh the mistakes that Mayor
Daley was making undercovering the
police brutality so that they would not
appear to be being unfair to the city of
Chicago and to Mayor Daley himself now I
mentioned the Electrical Workers strike
which the The Fallout from that in the
main was that for this convention you
needed thousands not hundreds thousands
of extra telephone lines uh installed
and since we have a range of age groups
in the room I'll just say like
telephones had wires that went into the
wall and if you add a major political
event like a convention you had to
install lots of extra telephones why
well first of all reporters needed
telephones to phone in their stories and
so this is a picture actually from the
New York Public Library that I found
that I thought was very uh kind of
beautiful but this would also this could
be any hotel in America and so ways in
the 1950s or 1960s a wall of wooden
telephone booths and if a major news
event happened every one of them would
be filled by a reporter on the phone uh
telling of calling in their story to
their newspaper so in addition to your
phone booths you needed extra lines
installed throughout town because
there's you know hundreds of thousands
of or many many thousand extra people in
town the networks needed these extra
lines to broadcast live outside the
convention hall as I've said they
couldn't set up their trucks outside in
the street because they didn't have the
electrical lines and when they found
some electrical lines they were
mysteriously cut
uh and that just sort of kept happening
um so there was obviously a little bit
of sabotage going on the delegates
themselves the thousands of people
inside the convention hall needed extra
telephone lines installed so they could
talk to each other because they didn't
have phones in their pockets and so how
were they going to uh talk about you
know here's how we can come up with a
new Vietnam War platform here's how we
can whatever kind of hobnobbing they
need to do was seriously stop me by this
extreme lack of telephones okay so that
just gives you a basic idea of how
important the telephone issue really was
so coming into Chicago the
assassinations the crisis of America the
Richard Nixon nomination and all these
things would be on your mind to say
you're a journalist driving into town
and as you come into town you would as
you were taking a cab down the streets
you would see temporary walls that have
been put up in front of vacant Lots they
wanted to cover up any spots that you
know their broken glass or like you know
signs of poverty they tried to hide
those they in installed new flowers
everywhere I mean the roots hadn't even
taken root they pulled them out of pots
and just put them around to make it look
like they're lots of flowers in Chicago
and in addition to that
you've got welcome signs for me your
daily everywhere hello Democrats welcome
to Chicago and it wasn't really an
option if you didn't feel like putting
in your window because they would be
like oh we'll send the health inspector
over right away to make sure and then
you were shut down so you just said yes
you took the signs in your window
um then let's say you're this
hypothetical journalist you get to your
hotel you want to call your boss and say
you've arrived you're ready to get to
work
the picture of Mayor Daley is on a
sticker in the Cradle of the phone right
welcome to the international Democratic
Convention again his face and then you
pick it up and you're like oh I can't
get a line right so it sort of added
insult to injury to see his face as you
couldn't get through because there
aren't enough electrical lines because
of the Electrical Workers strike so that
gives you more sense of the the scene on
the ground for journalists arriving in
town and then there are these
technological issues that I referenced
earlier
um cameras and this is actually an image
from 1964 uh from the convention in the
Republican convention but it looked very
similar to the sorts of cameras you'd
see on the floor in 1968. you've got
this thing on your back if you're a
cameraman and there were not camera
women at the time
um that weighs almost 100 pounds and
then he's holding up this camera in
front of him as well they need to have a
cable coming out going to a sound man
again all men
um or sometimes the cable would actually
go to the reporter they would have to
skip the sale man and just you know the
the reporter would be reporting and also
doing working his own sound system so
it's not a very portable system this is
technically a portable system because of
this giant plastic harness that you can
use so you don't theoretically fall down
when you put this giant thing on and you
walk around the convention hall so these
signs of things would already be a bit
awkward in the street but of course they
were impossible because of the
electrical issues another option would
be oh what about a 16 millimeter camera
which weighs only 20 to 30 pounds
depending on if it's got a battery in it
or whether it's hand cranked right which
would make it lighter can hoist it on
your shoulder on the issue there again
for some of the younger people in the
room is that you had to develop film so
you shoot this film in the street and
then you have to rush it back to the
convention center on motorcycles
um and they have trailers set up there
where you can develop the film in the
trailers and then they have technicians
there uh the networks you know to edit
it and to get it on the air so it's not
the most
um efficient sort of system it's
possible but it's extra hard because you
need to turn on lights if it's at night
for example to shoot so you have these
handheld large sort of Lights you turn
them on and then the police immediately
go aha I see that light I see there's a
journalist and they take a night stick
and they break the light and then they
probably break the camera as well
so uh journalists are being targeted and
just having a light so that you can
shoot with your camera is a sort of
Bullseye on your back so 16 millimeter
was was not a great option that said
there is some uh 60 millimeter footage
from the convention uh that has uh
that that that remains that we still
study now and we watch today
um another issue going into Chicago and
I already mentioned this the sort of
perceived trustworthiness of of the
networks and the perceived neutrality of
the networks
um you've got Walter Cronkite as the
main Anchorman for uh for CBS and he's
regularly rated in surveys as the most
trusted man in America until the
convention where everything goes to hell
in a handbasket you also have NBC's
Huntley and Brinkley who are likewise
seen as fairly neutral perhaps in their
private life they tend to vote one way
or another and that might come through
in a New Yorker magazine profile but the
public perception is that they are doing
their new their their jobs in a very
sort of neutral manner okay so I
mentioned how
you know if you turn on a light the bulb
would get busted out
um the big picture here was that
journalists that I'm about to show a of
some violent content I'll just give you
a warning
um journalists were being targeted in
the street and this is an image of an
NBC News
um journalist with a freelance
photographer and you see their heads are
are bloody because they've been beaten
by um with night sticks
um and one thing that's fascinating here
is that if you read uh like interviews
with journalists of the time who
recovered Detroit or Washington DC or
Newark or other cities that had had
uprisings where the people were in the
street and there was uh looting and
arson and police were shooting
journalists generally felt
that the police kind of had their back
that they were there as a neutral person
trying to do their job they knew they
were in danger they were in the street
in the middle of all of this
conflagration and so on and they knew
that they could be harmed but it was
just part of their job but they felt
that the police had their back the
police would actually say get out of the
way you know we're gonna whatever they
would sort of help them out in certain
ways
Chicago was really different
this is the first time when journalists
are saying uh
uh you know we are actually the prime
target for attack and of course another
exception there was the coverage of
civil rights in the South where
journalists were off were quite often
targeted so so there's that as well
um but the the level of targeting of
journalists was really sort of over the
top this is a very famous image of a
Chicago photojournalist Paul secara uh
he's capturing a shot of himself being
maced for being a photojournalist and
he's actually held the camera up to his
face to try to keep the mace out of his
face and taken a shot as the mace kind
of comes toward him and I say this is
famous this is one of the images from
Chicago that's been reproduced quite a
bit over the years
um and it
you know if it were today it would be in
color but I feel like it resonates quite
strongly today we've seen a lot of
images of police
um harming people over the past few
years and um that the The Smiling is of
course one of the most uh terrifying
things here this sort of sense of
enjoying what what they're doing and
that is not uncommon in these images
from Chicago it's very uh alarming
another famous image is of this New York
Times photographer Barton Silverman
being beaten for being a new
photographer and one thing that's
typical about this image is how
overwhelmed he is by so many people that
that you know 10 cops to one person and
in Chicago
there are 10 000 protesters who are
protesting the convention itself
protesting the war
um there are a hundred thousand people
working security it's ten to one
so that includes um the entire Chicago
police force the National Guard uh
Secret Service private security agencies
um so the the uh the the sort of
Overkill here is is quite extreme
um in addition to targeting protesters
or you know hippies or some kind of
people derided as long hairs as it were
at the time uh just regular citizens in
the street if you were in downtown
Chicago uh you were probably going to be
in trouble during those four days in
August and this is a lesser-known image
and one thing I've tried to do in my
research on this is kind of retrieve
images that haven't entered our mythical
Archive of the images of Chicago this is
a UPI news service image of a woman
fleeing on her bicycle and her child has
been tear gassed and there are reports
of of you know people just driving
through downtown on a motorcycle they
get hit with a uh hit by a police
officer where they have the window down
in their car and they get mace through
the window so it was a kind of uh
indiscriminate attack on anyone who just
happened to be out in public
the mo one of the most famous images of
Chicago is this one in front of the
Chicago Hilton Hotel
so this is from what came to be known as
the Battle of Michigan Avenue on the
third day of the convention
and uh these images from this I've put
in quotation marks police Riot I'll
explain what that means in a moment they
feel TV viewers with anger and
specifically anger against the network
news which was seen as uh at fault for
showing these images of police brutality
um and for showing bias against the
Chicago beliefs by showing what they did
by reporting what they did
um I put police right in quotation marks
because I'm actually referring to a
famous statement from The Walker report
which was the name of the government
study that was commissioned right after
the convention and
speaking of bias one thing that's so
fascinating about the Walker report is
that the creators of that report
um you know commissioned by the
government tell us what happened and
they had to do this report in large part
because people were so angry and assumed
that the networks had just somehow made
up this story that it really wasn't that
bad or or whatever the protesters
deserved it because they provoked the
police and they deserve to be beaten
this was the common line so the
government funds this report and the
people creating the report go into it
you read interviews with them later
really with a very strong bias toward
the police they assume that what they're
going to find is that the news really
did misreport this that people were very
provocative of police and and sort of
were asking for it and ultimately
deserved to be beaten and as they triple
triple check their facts they found that
that was not the case that this really
had been what they described as a police
Riot that it was that that protesters
certainly had engaged in some uh
activities that were you know like
hurling obscenities at police hurling
objects at them sometimes it's not that
they didn't do anything to defend
themselves but the police really were at
fault
um against everything they felt going
into the study these were the results
that they came up with
um in the name of bringing in a few
other images outside of our mythical
Archive of Chicago images that get
recycled in say Ken Burns documentaries
or PBS documentaries whatever I thought
I'd show you just a couple more from the
Battle of Michigan Avenue uh in the
McCarthy headquarters one of the
candidates had headquarters in the hotel
and they brought people inside and set
up a sort of emergency field hospital
and they tore up the bed sheets and put
them on people's heads uh mostly
headsets were a huge amount of the
injuries were
um and NBC had hired a war photographer
David Douglas Duncan to do freelance
work for him for them uh which is
fascinating this fellow has just come
back from from the Tet Offensive right
from doing this combat footage and then
he finds himself doing combat footage um
in the U.S
um another image that I find quite
striking is uh from that same night is
this room where everyone's being treated
and cared for and they're watching TV
and in effect they're watching TV of
what happened to them because it's not
live because it takes three hours after
this battle happens over three hours for
it to actually show up on TV so it ends
up being around midnight when when
American viewers and the people have
been beaten see what happened on
television
so after all of this a survey uh two
months later by the University of
Michigan
asked respondents if they had heard
about the police and demonstrators in
Chicago and what they thought about the
level of police violence so there was a
general sense in the culture that uh you
know people were angry and
Etc but how could you gauge this so they
tried to crunch some numbers on this and
what they found was that 12 percent had
not heard what was going on which is
kind of amazing because these are images
that in contemporary parlance you know
went viral they wouldn't say that then
but they were not only on late at night
when they finally got to the convention
hall but they were still photos were in
newspapers they were in magazines they
were the images the moving images
repeated on the on the television news
throughout the country for days
afterwards uh it was hard not to see
these images but 12 people 12 of The
People's surveys said they had they
weren't aware
12 didn't know what they thought about
it
18 of Americans surveyed felt that too
much force had been used in Chicago 23
uh sorry 32 percent thought it was the
right amount of force and 25 felt that
it was not enough Force
um so that is you know 57 of people who
are uh uh pro-police coming out of this
um
which is it's it's it's amazing it's a
very high number
um and at this point I'll just add for a
few more numbers the American population
is about 88 uh White identified
Americans uh so this is seen as like a
survey of of white attitudes
um at the time and I'll also add that
the Democratic National Convention was
the single highest rated program in all
of 1968. so just to give you a sense of
how many people were actually watching
this not just the people who saw the
aftermath of the images
okay so what are a few takeaways at this
point well a majority of Americans sided
with the police in Chicago against
protesters hippies and yippies and by
extension against the media most felt
the TV over reported police brutality
didn't provide enough context
um that showed why police protesters
deserved the treatment they got and the
reality uh from my own research findings
is that the media under reported police
violence in Chicago out of the sense of
fairness and the the professional Norms
that I cited earlier
um five percent of the coverage uh okay
95 of NBC's coverage and cbs's coverage
was inside the convention hall and three
to five percent was in the streets so
the amount of violence they showed was
actually pretty small right uh
percentage-wise and yet people felt that
the news had shown too much
um what's fascinating to me when I think
about this in comparison to today and
these reactions is and I'm not sure
anyone live streaming this can see my
hands but I'm holding my hands up to my
face let's say that I'm holding a camera
and I'm filming this room right now like
this okay so the critique at the time
was well you you showed this but you
didn't pivot left or right right so you
didn't show the whole room and if you
had taken more footage and edit it
together better you could have told a
better story
all right you just did a bad job you
didn't get the right images you didn't
tell the right story we know that
stories are created they're not just
found they're not just neutrally out in
the world but they have to be creative
and put together and that's a very
different argument than someone saying
Okay you put your camera here and what
you showed me was fake
it simply didn't happen
um now there's you know that there's
all kinds of ways to explain that I mean
in a sense it's a kind of ontological
shift in you know how you perceive
picture telling in reality and of course
today we have deep fakes and we have
imagery that can be much more literally
fake than what you could see in 1968 but
obviously it also speaks to a new level
of authoritarianism and what President
Biden recently called semi-fascism or
what one might simply call fascism uh in
terms of of attitudes about the news
among other things
um I talked about the the findings from
that University of Michigan study which
are rather famous but there are less
often cited findings from that same
study uh about attitudes of black
respondents which at this point are
about 10 of the U.S population uh in the
entire uh pool of black respondents
overall 63 percent said that Police use
too much force for blacks under 50 uh
the the percentage was 78 percent of
people who felt that police used too
much force and for blacks with at least
some college education Police use too
much force 82 percent of the time so
obviously we see a very big difference
here
um overwhelmingly in both the
alternative black press and in
mainstream print and electronic sources
when I say alternative I mean like
there's magazines like uh Jet and Ebony
and then there's black newspapers
um the Amsterdam news the Chicago
Defender the Pittsburgh Courier so these
black newspapers as well are part of
that alternative uh black media
but also in the mainstream media New
York Times Etc one hears black Americans
saying uh Chicago demonstrated or at
least should have demonstrated to the
white majority the reality of police
brutality that blacks face every day and
heading into Chicago uh uh the Reverend
Jesse Jackson predicted is speaking to
some organizers he said you know it
looks very likely people are going to be
beaten in Chicago because Mayor Daley is
saying as much before the convention
even starts and he predicted that this
could be helpful for the movement
because it would bring home the reality
of what police brutality was like for
white middle class Americans for the
so-called silent majority
um
I I and of course you know that that
didn't happen I do think that this white
on white violence and this is this part
of the the findings of of my research on
this
um was a kind of Tipping Point for
Americans and there's a kind of
incoherence here because on the one hand
a lot of viewers of you know white
middle class if you were seeing this on
TV they already have very negative
attitudes about hippies and hippies
about war protesters you know long hairs
um if you've ever seen Dragnet episode
from 1967 the kind of uh right-wing
hostility towards anyone with long hair
or a beard who looked different who
didn't shower enough these kinds of
complaints and and sort of the disgust
in the culture was was pretty widespread
so on the one hand you have people sort
of cheering on the police but on the
other hand you have people who have
grown tragically sort of used to seeing
uh uh white on black violence in the
course of of watts and Detroit and and
other uprisings throughout the country
and
the white on white violence is the kind
of Tipping Point for them sort of
feeling like wow now things have really
sort of gone over the edge now America
has reached a crisis point and you know
can we what can we do to fix it how can
what what is our way forward and uh
unfortunately uh in my opinion the the
result the the answer to that question
what can we possibly do what's the
election of Richard Nixon that's sort of
how this played out
um
I argue that the network news didn't
fail viewers by exhibiting a so-called
liberal bias towards the Chicago police
but they did fail viewers in certain
ways and now I want to take just a few
minutes to move inside the convention
hall most of the historical traction
around Chicago has been outside in the
streets but if we move inside the
convention hall
um we found that in addition to
undercovering uh violence in the name of
fairness and so on in the streets as I
already mentioned
they also avoided uh sort of deep
contextualization that would help
viewers get past the horse race elements
of the nomination process and this is
probably true of a lot of conventions so
you get there and just like who's ahead
who's behind what are the votes what are
the numbers and those are sort of the
professional Norms but what that meant
was they were missing out on the social
justice social justice issues that were
in play in the convention hall
um where you had challenging delegates
from so many states uh from uh Georgia
Alabama Tennessee North Carolina Texas
Mississippi virtually all the southern
states delegates showed up saying
the delegates that that the official
delegates brought in were not properly
elected we weren't allowed to vote on
these delegates there's voter
suppression in play and we would like to
be seated instead of say the delegates
that that came in from Mississippi and
in Mississippi
um they won and the other delegations uh
lost uh in different ways it's very
complicated procedural stuff and that's
I think why the Network's undercovered
it in part is it's really hard to
explain all the ins and outs and and the
the Roberts rules of orders that were in
play
um but they they ultimately said as
procedural stuff and they didn't really
get into the social justice issues that
were happening so I feel like that was a
failure of the news in Chicago
um they did cover some aspects of the
crisis in the convention hall this is a
photo of the uh some of the pro peace
delegates in the convention hall holding
up these stop the war signs which if you
look closely you can see the fold lines
and the signs and that these are uh
these protest signs lines were paid were
printed overnight secretly on pages of
the Chicago Tribune
they didn't arrive in Chicago with a
nice paper order they'd put in place
with a contract with a printing company
it was all very seat of the pants once
they realized they wouldn't be allowed
to bring in their protest materials so
they had to print these overnights fold
them up and hide them in their clothing
to bring them in because you were only
allowed to come in with Hubert Humphrey
material and material that supported the
Lyndon Mains Johnson sort of line on the
war so you had to sneak in the
anti-war signs that you wanted to and
people brought in bed sheets they stole
bed sheets from the hotel and they
painted stuff the war on the bed sheets
they put hid things in their hats
because the women wore these giant hats
and they pulled them out of their hats I
mean it was really very inventive
um and the media covered that pretty
well it was a good story it was an
entertaining story in many ways
um they also covered violence against
themselves uh Dan Rather was famously
slugged by dailies thugs which I've put
in quotation marks not because they
weren't thugs but I'm quoting Walter
Cronkite who sort of lost his cool when
Daley was was or when uh Dan Rather was
punched and fell to the ground less
often remembered is that Mike Wallace
also got caught up in a tussle and
punched the ground and after that he was
actually arrested taken out of the uh
the convention hall
um uh in terms of a delegate protests uh
we did see a reasonable amount of
coverage of Julian Bond who was
protesting the Georgia delegation that
had been selected by Governor Lester
Maddox one of the most famous
segregationists in America sort of uh
just up there with with George Wallace
another key moment inside the convention
hall that the convent that the um uh
networks undercovered was Fannie Lou
hamer's appearance speaking for the
Alabama challenging delegate so she had
been a key player in 1964. she's back in
68. the Mississippi Challengers were
seated in 68 and now she's speaking up
for the Alabama Challengers who
ultimately lose and I'm just going to
put in a quick plug for this new book
until I'm Free by Keisha Blaine who is
now a professor at Brown University that
speaks to the importance of family
Hammers and historical figure and as the
subtitle puts it her enduring message to
America I want to highly encourage that
one
for you to pick that up
um and and finally uh there's another
issue that they didn't cover very well
at the convention which was the uh
Reverend Channing Phillips was the first
national party Black nominee for
president it was a symbolic nomination
uh no one you know everyone knew that he
wasn't going to win he wasn't a
contender but um it is uh quite uh
interesting that this is the first time
this happened at a convention uh in
1968. so a name that has has sort of
largely been lost to history I think and
I'll just show you one last image from
inside the convention hall uh this is uh
Eddie Anderson a young delegate from
California
um as things come to a head with the uh
Bond uh Julian Bond challenge against
the Georgia delegation things just sort
of spiral out of control in the
convention hall it's 2 45 in the morning
and they have business plan to keep them
going to at least 5 30 in the morning
um but the hall just erupts in in Anger
around what's been happening around the
Georgia delegation and then uh this
fellow end Eddie Anderson sets his
credentials on fire
or he tries to they're not really very
flammable it's a symbolic gesture and
the News Rush is over because of course
this is well this is amazing like
visually it's quite a story this guy
with the dashiki and the bees and he's
burning the card and this is sort of the
straw that breaks the camel's back
finally it's over and they adjourn early
and then pick up again the next day
okay so that's just a handful of images
from inside so that we're not only
thinking about what the you know issues
of social justice and brutality and so
on are in the streets but also what was
happening in the convention hall itself
um let's turn to the aftermath these are
some immediate aftermath of people's
anger at the networks as I've already
said letters running to CBS are 11 to 1
against the network uh in terms of media
responses uh the local Chicago media
fights back they create a new
publication called Chicago journalism
review which is sort of the Chicago
version of Columbia journalism review if
you've heard of that a publication that
is about news by professional news
people but with with a strong critical
Edge how can we be critical of news that
our our colleagues our peers are
producing
um another immediate reaction on the
media front is a number of films
produced by an upstart film group in
Chicago called film group
um and I'm going to show you a four
minute clip and then head into my final
final comments from a film called
American Revolution 2 Battle of Chicago
which they released in 1969.
um and I will just note that there is
some profanity in this clip and um I
will also note there's a cutaway there's
two cutaways that might be hard to
understand if you don't have all the
context one is uh they have some white
folks from Appalachia who are in the
film because one of film group's
objectives was to get black people
Chicago and Appalachian transport to
Chicago to talk about their common cause
around labor issues and suppression by
Mayor Daley and you'll also see a shot
of Mayor Daley when he is talking about
his shoot to kill and shoot to maim
order that he put out during the Chicago
Uprising after the the death of Dr King
so just a little context to help that
make more sense for you see um black
people have been demonstrating and going
on for I don't know how long
and um
you know we've been getting our heads
beat and whatnot we knew what was going
to happen when those folks went down
there because we have seen the pigs on
the scene we know what he's like we know
what he's capable of just being a damn
Pig oinking and beaten and walking the
streets I'm sick of these damn pigs
walking our streets and so everybody
gets uptight when a few hunkies get
their heads beat what did they do when
we was getting our heads people so I
don't even want to deal with why they
got their heads beat no damn Walker
reporting up whatever whatever else
that's going on I just want to deal with
black and black liberation my scene is
picking up my damn gun and I'm a mother
have my baby in one hand my gun in the
other and walking up to some hunky all
hunkies saying I'm here [ __ ] to
get what's mad
you know like all over the city of
Chicago
each person like black Pirates doing its
own thing and Another Irish power or
whatever you want to call it your name
we're all people and all poor folks
and like the Democratic Convention you
know and they're uh shortening their
belly sticks and that and they seem you
know they didn't care what kind of
person it was they worked on you with
that thing we realized a whole lot so
like Dudley and all we realize we're in
the same boat Paula flows from the
barrel of a gun
did you feel that something had to be
done about daily before the Democratic
Convention right let me put out that
shoot dude when he put out that shoot to
kill man the man that just got power man
he just instead of having got so much
power man until uh he worse than Hitler
I said to him very emphatically and very
definitely
that in order to be issued immediately
under his signature
to shoot to kill any arsonist sure
everybody get a gun and go down the
street and every dark one you see shoot
you know what I mean you're all evil but
uh after it kind of calmed down and
everything else why there was a
different story to him to shoot domain
or [ __ ] anyone looting
any stores in our city isn't he after
all the men who coined the phrase good
government is good politics
and he thinks good government includes
the suppression of uh of uh leftist
descent I did it man when they had this
convention about three of them thought
you know India put out that uh shoot to
kill all that you understand so his
colleagues coming down too and say look
here man you got to modify this thing so
he goes and modified but still mean the
same thing but when they had a
convention here they said this is my
[ __ ] and you all can't do what y'all
gonna do so he figured that these black
Brothers is going to start some of these
things so he gets these police all hyped
up you understand you know like you're
gonna be playing football or something
like that you're not a coach keep
coaching and tell you and say well look
at that we got to do this and we got to
do that so naturally then when uh this
convention comes he's hippies and if
it's clear but ain't no black folks they
don't care who they're there they're
gonna whip somebody they got to whoop
somebody you know you said the police
was there the police all this military
enforcement there for the black people
there that's right man but uh we we was
cool we laid dead we gonna dig and see
what's happening but again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Athletics scholarships and so on and so
forth so uh we'll deal to do that yeah
he blocked off a whole neighborhood now
and people live there they can't raise
they Wonder it's hot they can't read
they want us now what kind of [ __ ] is
that huh you know this man don't you
oh
you may not have been able to see the
watermark but this is from Chicago film
archives and this material is online so
you could watch all the Productions of
Chicago film group on your own and I
highly encourage it
um even this small little clip is so
resonant there's so many interesting
things happening you've got this one
young woman who is just like I don't
care about the convention it's
irrelevant to me I care about black
power and black people and then you have
another fellow who says uh you know at
the end that he notes that this is white
on white violence you know that he notes
it like the Bourgeois doctors and
lawyers and so on are seeing their own
children being beat uh and and you know
how impactful this was and also you
notice that like black people were sort
of out of this there were there were
black protesters in Chicago but very few
it's a very small number it was very
very much a white event and a lot of uh
the local blacks either sort of hid out
or left town because if you were known
as an agitator or a troublemaker Daley
was likely to arrest you before the
convention happened just to come to your
house and and have his his police take
you away so a lot of people if they
could they left town
okay so these are the sorts of
perspectives that you know we're sorely
lacking from TV news coverage of events
and you know they show what the what
image making in the hands of the people
rather than sanctioning corporate media
makers can produce a much wider range of
perspectives
um just to quickly finish up here
um I already said that you know one of
the aftermaths of this was Nixon uh
getting elected and he basically
weaponized the idea of liberal media
bias and that idea became nationalized
and normalized it was no longer
necessarily a right wing or Fringe kind
of position as it had been before the
convention in the long term is this the
beginning of a crisis that culminates in
Trump's fake news accusation well not
exactly right that's thin history and
you don't want to just draw a straight
line but maybe you draw a more of a
dotted line between these events and we
can guardedly see this as a Tipping
Point moment
um the idea of bias got traction it grew
so it's a seed that took root it found
roots in right-wing fundraising and as
an element of the culture wars which is
obviously still an issue today
um
interestingly you know 50 years later
the Waka reports conclusions are widely
accepted the notion that what we saw was
actually a police ride is widely
believed but there's uh no cultural
memory of the dominant notion in 1968
that TV news had gotten the story wrong
um the idea that the news media is
inherently liberal though has stuck as a
rhetorical weapon of the right
today we hold cameras and telephones in
our pockets Gathering of images of
police brutality is no longer wholly
dependent on the largest of media
institutions
so what difference does or should that
make
that is exactly what we are here to
discuss today and tomorrow thank you I
will stop there and we do have a few
minutes for discussion questions we have
like 10 minutes so I would love to hear
from you
[Applause]
if you have a question please come up to
the mic on the side
and there's one here too
hello Professor Hendershot thank you so
much uh I'm Charisse lapree MIT Alum and
uh professor at Syracuse and I was
actually just having a thought the other
day I was really taken by the
distinction between
the shot
being short-sighted not showing the
broad Thing versus what's in the shot is
fake and one of the things that I've
been really
thinking about is when we watch the
footage
the young woman who shot the footage of
George Floyd's last moments we see other
people holding cameras but that other
footage has not had the same
traction uh and so I'm now starting to
think well where is that footage is it
just living on people's cameras did it
never get shared after uh her name
became public and she became a public
figure I wouldn't want to like good on
her thank you I wouldn't want to be that
so uh it was just just a thought that I
think I would love to hear your
perspective on when we know that there's
other footage but that has not been the
footage thank you
um
I will say that uh around
any major news event or news that
becomes a major news you know things
that happen they become major events uh
news agencies are looking for every
single person who had a camera there and
reaching out whether it's through social
media emailing people whatever they can
do to to collect that footage so it's
it's impossible to me to think that all
those other cameras people holding all
these other cameras weren't contacted by
Network news by journalists and so on by
online news aggregators whoever
um so the footage surely has been seen
and I wonder if the footage that has
become the footage right that we take is
the iconic footage is simply and it's
horrible to say like the best shot the
best vantage point that showed the most
you know is that why it is the uh
winning footage I hate to use that word
but that has become the footage of that
moment and my guess is that is probably
correct
um and that other pieces of footage were
uh were also acquired you know for legal
use but have not trended in media uh in
and then reproduced so much
um because they were from a different
angle they were from the wrong angle
that kind of thing that is my
um
Instinct on this I would also suspect
that and this is what's going to feel
you know different from 68 for sure is
that the conspiracy theories around
these other images are probably abundant
somewhere that someone's saying well if
you look at that guy on the left he sees
what's really happening which is not a
murder at all this kind of thing but we
haven't seen the footage so we don't
know and it's just it's like the
Zapruder footage and the grassy knoll
kind of stuff of like oh if we could
just see the other images we'd see
something different
um so uh I'm sure there's some fomenting
around those other images too
but thank you for for asking about that
I think it's a really uh important
question
yeah
all right along that lines I was
wondering if you could talk about the
process of the mythologizing of specific
images you talked about how there are
really some images that have really
become part of this mythology and you've
done a lot of work to find those images
that were kind of ignored so what made
an image one to be mythologized and what
made one that was potentially equally
powerful to be forgotten forgotten yeah
that's a that's a very good question
um uh the question was about you know
what makes certain images mythologize
from this moment and others not and
the Battle of Michigan Avenue so-called
right on Wednesday night that is 17
minutes of police beating people in
which the networks ran in full hard to
imagine now in a short attention called
spam culture of you know 10 second news
Clips right
um that's the footage that gained the
most traction because it was most widely
seen initially that's part of why it
gained traction
um there's two kinds of footage there
one is the overhead this was actually a
spot where there were electrical cables
right in front of the hotel and so there
are TV cameras on top of trucks but
they're not transmitting live but
they're capturing images They're
bringing back the convention hall for
Walter Cronkite to you know put on the
air and those images from on top of the
trucks are high angle and kind of far
away
and then the local affiliate of CBS
comes in with 16 millimeter cameras and
they're on the ground and so they get a
more personal approach because you can
see people's faces as it's happening and
uh MEC didn't have those people on the
ground so CBS had better footage because
you could actually see people and
identify people and so on and
CBS
probably repeated that footage on the
ground quite a bit because it was very
very good footage and in that way
contributed to the dissemination and as
I said they went viral using
contemporary language but could just
contributed to that vast spread right of
these images
um and then you have you know these
these a handful of still images I'm sure
a lot of people took still images
especially journalists but their cameras
were destroyed so often that a lot of
that stuff
um uh didn't come out so in a way part
of the issue is a sort of positive
images because so many were destroyed so
you focus on the ones that you have
um and
the next stage of answering that
question would be to like go to the
producers of WGBH television like
Vietnam and television history from I
think it was 1984.
um where this is one of the first places
I saw this imagery in you know a few
years after this this famous documentary
series came out they had one episode
called the home front USA
and it was a key moment in 84 of
mythologizing the 60s and what protest
was and a handful of images and the
Chicago images were right there
and then I started noticing as I watched
more documentaries made after that up to
say the Ken Burns Vietnam series that
came out a year or two ago
um I keep seeing the same street images
and I don't know if it's because WGBH
selected these in the early 80s but that
could be part of it you know
um that I mean I've seen these images on
Colbert you know where she's doing a
parody he did a parody of about um the
former president where he's comparing it
to like not he's comparing now in 1968
and he cuts back and forth her imagery
and he shows BLM imagery and then he
shows Chicago 68 you know and they're
the same some of the same images that I
just showed you
um so they kept being recycled and it
becomes a sort of
anomalous when you see an image you
hadn't seen before you're like oh this
well this one how did this get in here
and one example of that is some very uh
on the second day so before the Battle
of Michigan Avenue
um there had been quite a bit of tear
gassing in the street and
uh about 1 30 in the morning Walter
Cronkite gets his hand on some 16
millimeter footage of a woman trying to
drive a sort of middle class a
middle-aged woman and a like a station
wagon trying to drive some kids away
hoop in tear gas and the National Guard
stops her and they put a grenade
launcher in her car
through the window a grenade launcher at
you know like at her head
um
and she's saying like why can't I just
leave with you know what's going on and
there's no voice over because it's like
so it's news like done
uh so it's so quick and dirty kind of
news like they got the footage they put
it together and Cronkite only interjects
once he just says uh that's a grenade
launcher just just to emphasize and then
at the end he says um
well I don't think any commentary needs
to be made you've all seen it
good night like he ends with that you
know and you think that that imagery
would have become iconic
um and it has eventually later you know
like over the past few years I've seen
it in some documentaries but it sort of
disappeared for 48 years
um so uh I'm not sure I haven't really
answered your question I've just said
correct things don't get mythologized
and you know how does it happen I don't
know
um but hopefully that gives you a little
bit of at least a sense of like how I
try to tell the story and and kind of
like a detective follow the leads and
figure out what got traction where
sure
thank you for your talk
um it's so unlike me to ask a technology
question but what resonated with me the
most about your talk was this moment
where the police were drawn to the light
in order to put it out yeah yeah right
uh so I feel like there's a lot to be
said here in the relationship between
bearing witness and shedding literal
light right and I'm wondering if much
was made about that fact
in 1968 right that is to say you know
here is this like literal technological
moment of shedding light and uh police
brutality looked like
wanting to suppress that truth telling
in by any means necessary
um
it's a great question I mean really
when people when the news reported on
the destruction of equipment like lights
cameras lenses
um they tended to say how much they cost
um not in a metaphorical way in a
literal way of like well that was a 300
lens you know what
um and
there's not a lot of talk of it uh among
media people because of their own
reluctance to be the story they wanted
to tell the story they didn't want to be
the story and that's part of the
undercovering of violence I think in
Chicago is a concern like it's not about
us we don't understand why police are
beating us because we haven't had this
problem uh all the time in the past but
if we report that
who cares about us it's about the
political event you know we're a neutral
party here to record it so getting into
issues like the discretion of the light
would be uh too self-serving would be
the sort of professional Norms that
would dictate talking about this or not
talking about it
um I will back up though and say that
this attack on on journalists was more
common at certain moments in the Deep
South during the the battles over um
desegregation and at Ole Miss when
there's a a white Riot about uh
integration
um Dan Rather is out with a a news a
cameraman he's working the sound the
cameraman working the camera they have
one light and they had a system
where they would turn on the light
count to 15 and then turn it off
um and run while they were shoot you
know stop enough that you could had to
to film but then run and so they were
using these short spurts so that the
light wouldn't be destroyed
and then at a certain point they part of
their problem was what one of the
dictums of shooting these kinds of
situations was you should go bloody and
go high
go for the the bloodiest images the
images of Confrontation and get as high
up as you can so that you're safe from
it and that's that CBS footage I was
referencing for the last question of
like on top of the news trucks and in
Ole Miss they couldn't find a high spot
so they were running along the ground
they would between those 15 seconds they
would lie on the ground because they
were being shot at and so on
um and that's the only time I've heard
someone actually like talk about the
light in a real and this is in one of
his Memoirs and really kind of dramatic
technical way that obviously has
resonance beyond the beyond the
technical
all right I have a couple from online
great
um first is more of just a comment said
wow this is powerful
uh and then the second one great
presentation
what do we make of violence against the
media or those bearing Witness
how does this how does that impact
future coverage and memory
wow wow
it impacts future coverage and memory
because if you can't cover it then you
know how do you create memory well just
to a large extent through images and
through collecting audio and then you
have people who are there and if they
haven't collected the images or the
audio then the memory is just inside
these physical bodies and they have to
tell it back to you and then someone a
filmmaker comes in and does an interview
with them and ah now we have the audio
because someone tells their memory uh of
what happened right so um it becomes a
sort of convoluted
rolling kind of process
now I'll stop with it there with that
question
any other questions oh here's one great
is that Chris hey man I'm good how are
you
you Heather thanks so much nice to see
you
um so it's kind of film nerdy question I
couldn't help but think of
um medium cool coming out right right
around this time so I'm wondering how
you situate that in relationship to what
you're saying about the news of how much
is it challenging that imagery how much
is it sort of countering it itself like
what impact did that have in
relationship to the TV news that you
yeah speaking of medium cool is a film
by Haskell wechsler who was famous as a
Director of Photography as a
cinematographer and then he made this
film about Chicago it's called medium
cool as a take on Marshall mcluhan who
had the idea of you know cool media
versus hot media and TV he thought was
cool not funky cool but cool versus hot
you know like like Anyway don't get me
going about Marshall mclu and I disagree
with him about many things
um but so he titled his film this way
and then he goes to Chicago during while
things are happening right and it's
scripted it's a mix of scripted material
starring Rob Robert Forster who you may
remember from Better Call Saul and
Breaking Bad
as a young man he's in this movie shot
in 68 that comes out in 69 and it's a
mix of documentary footage of the time
and then uh you know scripted material
and enforcer gets involved with someone
from Appalachia which speaks exactly to
these images from the Chicago from film
group you know where they're very
interested in this as a political issue
in Chicago
um and along with that Network news
footage
uh those images from from medium cool
become part of the historical record and
part of that assembly of images we have
but uh unofficial in other words I I
emphasize the kind of top-down news
production but here we have an
independent filmmaker who happened to be
in town and managed to take images I
would encourage you to check it out if
you're interested in this topic that
said it's not 90 images in the street
it's maybe
10 to 20 images on the street and it
ends with um the crises in the street
and with tear gas and with shots of the
news Vans going by with the cameras
stuck on top and so you do get some of
that documentary footage
um but it's not exclusively that kind of
footage more broadly the film is a
critique of uh TV news just exactly for
what I just said that go bloody and go
high a critique of the go bloody part of
that a critique of the unfeelingness of
being an objective neutral recorder okay
so on the one hand one might celebrate
neutrality neutrality and news Gathering
that you you don't gather news just to
make an argument for or against
something but this film is arguing like
how can we be neutral
when we're dealing with fascism
authoritarianism Vietnam these this is
not a time for news gatherers to be
neutral
and so I think that is um a key
contribution that Medium cool makes to
this part of the discussion
so check out the Criterion disc
any um
okay great
comment it's more of a it's a question
and comment um
so what I uh like what stands out a lot
about this
um and I guess what I like about it and
that there's a lot to like about the the
violence but um it makes me think about
um how you know Martin Luther King
wanted the protest to be captured on the
media so that people can see all this
racism and get to see um like let's see
like let people know what's happening to
us what's happening to black people and
what I like about what you've done is
the extent to which you've highlighted
the violence against the media also
because I don't think that
it well I know I mean and from from my
being a teacher from my being a student
that that just wasn't talked about as
much as it's like the violence against
um black people and it makes me wonder
though because the media is in charge if
any of that like was to
um like how it makes me think about how
much it contributed to racism in the
sense of it's like all right there's
white people that are like there's a
story out there about these white people
that are already being racist against
black people and we don't want to make
it seem like that white people were
harmful to other white people like let's
not make it seem like white people were
those you know at that time were just
like that cruel or that bad so I don't
know if you have any thoughts on why
a lot of this violence against the media
story just wasn't told as much and I
appreciate you bringing it to light
thank you
um I mean it wasn't told as much because
the media wanted to de-emphasize it
again that idea we don't want to be the
story we want to tell the story and
following the convention with so many
attacks on them the I mean just from a
sort of public relations standpoint the
last thing that people wanted to do was
say like well we were beaten up look how
Dan Rather was beaten uh and so that was
really underplayed underplayed and Dan
Rather was sort of a you know kind of a
macho kind of like well it's holidays
work Walter it's all fine you know
everyone kind of underplayed it because
that was like the professional Norm but
it was also something that really uh was
Amplified after it after the attacks and
uh a great example of that
uh not telling that story is that in TV
guide and I'm going to say maybe six
months I may not be Memory right but the
head of NBC News Reuben Frank wrote a
piece for TV Guide about the convention
and TV Guide at that point had the
highest distribution of any magazine in
America
right if you wanted to hit the biggest
number of people in a magazine it was
either TV Guide or Reader's Digest a TV
Guide had more just a little more than
Reader's Digest and Reuben Frank had
already cataloged all the news coverage
and found okay we did uh three percent
of Street violence and 97 in the
convention hall whereas CBS did more
like 5 in 95 okay so he puts out those
numbers and he basically said don't
blame the messenger we showed you this
little piece of what we saw
and it's what we saw you know and you
know so he's sort of just fighting for
the objective reality of these images
and
he deliberately does not mention
anything about the attacks on the news
and in you know internal memos he says
like I just told the story this way you
know and he got praise from uh Robert
Sarnoff and all you know the all the
bigwigs over him were like yes this is
perfect thank you you went to the
mainstream venue and you didn't make us
look whiny and you didn't make it look
like we were saying we were the victims
you just stood up for journalistic
integrity and that is a journalist
Integrity is a real thing but it's also
a mythologized thing it's also about
professional norms and and the and the
ethics of of professionals but that's
how that violence against the media got
de-escalated and you really didn't I
mean during the Civil Rights crises when
journalists were under attack like Dan
Rather at Ole Miss like I was just
saying like they didn't talk about that
then it was something that would come
out five or ten years later in a memoir
that's when you're allowed to tell your
personal story you're writing as an
important figure telling your Memoir not
as a newsman you know you wouldn't go on
TV and say this is a terrible thing that
happened to me at Ole Miss you save it
for your memoir
thank you
okay I think that is the last for our
questions
um please join me in thanking Professor
Hendershot for her talk
[Applause]